[Applause]
another terrifying night in colombia's
third largest city cali
videos shot by residents of two working
class neighborhoods apparently show the
police shooting indiscriminately against
protesters
the morning after the scenes of
destruction were unmistakable
the mayor said at least five people were
killed and 33
injured we condemn in an absolute way
any expression of violence and
expression that puts the life integrity
and property of the men and women
of this territory at risk the western
city of cali has become the epicenter of
the ongoing protests
against the social and economic policies
of president ivan duque
on tuesday the united nations and the
european union
condemned the excessive use of force on
part of colombia's security forces to
try and contain the unrest
we are deeply alarmed at developments in
the city of calif
in colombia where police opened fire
overnight on demonstrations protesting
against tax reforms
reportedly killing and injuring a number
of people
we express our profound shock at the
events there
and stress our solidarity with those who
have lost their lives
as well as the injure and their families
the white house also issued a statement
urging the utmost restraint by public
forces
and asking the government to investigate
any human rights violation
but colombia's defense minister
responded saying colombia's forces
respect human rights and blamed criminal
gangs for the violence
our national police our army and our
navy act in strict compliance with the
law
these vandals that we have already
denounced act systematically
deliberately and are financed by
criminal organizations
and they have the objective of
destabilizing certain regions
every day they change their objectives
yesterday the objective was the police
orders to shoot our police officers
despite the violence the demonstrations
will continue
which started as a protest against tax
hikes
has billowed to a nationwide cry against
inequalities and now
police brutalities major unions have
called for another nationwide day of
demonstrations on wednesday
while cities like kali are bracing for
what could be
another night of terror alessandro
rampietti al jazeera bogota